Здоров'я громадян чи дотримання усіх демократичних свобод?
Пандемія коронавірусу у світі змушує запроваджувати карантин,
який обмежує базове право на свободу.
Аби це вимушене тимчасове обмеження було максимально ефективним
впроваджують додатковий контроль за допомогою мобільних застосунків.
У Польщі влада автоматично створює акаунти для громадян,
які повернулися з-за кордону у застосунку "Домашній карантин".
Принцип роботи додатка схожий з українським "Дій вдома".
Громадяни, які перебувають на карантині,
у відповідь на надісланий запит мають зробити селфі.
Завдяки геолокації та системі розпізнавання обличчя встановлюється особа
та звіряється адреса із зазначеною у формі напередодні.
Міністерство цифровізації Польщі стверджує, що завдяки додатку
користувачі також зможуть отримати швидкий доступ
до гарячої лінії зв'язку із соціальною службою,
яка може надавати ліки або продукти харчування в окремих випадках.
Інститут імені Роберта Коха представив мобільний додаток Corona-Datenspende,
призначений для збору даних щодо поширення коронавірусу у ФРН.
Використання його - добровільне і можливе під псевдонімом.
Користувачам необхідно  ввести свій поштовий індекс, стать, вік, зріст і вагу.
Дані використають для створення онлайн-мапи Німеччини,
де рівень зараження можна буде побачити за поштовим індексом.
Дослідників цікавить частота пульсу користувачів у спокої,
а також інформація про їхні періоди активності та сну.
По ним додаток  може розпізнати типові симптоми, пов'язані з COVID-19.
Натомість міністр закордонних справ Німеччини Гайко Маас
виступає за створення єдиного мобільного додатку для всіх 27 країн ЄС,
аби відстежувати та запобігати поширенню хвороби на всій території Євросоюзу.
Додаток "Код здоров'я" розробила китайська компанія,
що займається інтернет-торгівлею "Алібаба".
Після завантаження додаток пропонує відповісти на низку запитань
і потім за своїм алгоритмом визначає, чи має людина залишатися вдома.
Додаток схвалений урядом та є обов'язковим для використання.
У співпраці з владою Китаю компанія розробила систему, яка присвоює
QR-коди трьох кольорів сотням мільйонів китайських користувачів онлайн-гаманця Alipay.
Зелений - дозволяє вільне пересування (зокрема - в метро),
жовтий - рекомендує тижневий домашній карантин, червоний - два тижні самоізоляції.
Застосунок передає дані про геолокацію користувача
та колір присвоєного QR-коду до поліції.
За даними розробника, його використовують вже 700 мільйонів громадян Китаю.
"Ви були поруч з тим, хто має позитивний тест на коронавірус.
Ви повинні негайно самоізолюватись вдома".
Таке повідомлення на смартфони вже отримали сотні ізраїльтян.
Прем'єр Ізраїлю Беньямін Нетаньяху дозволив службі внутрішньої розвідки
використовувати глобальну базу даних
і відстежувати переміщення тих, хто заразився коронавірусом.
Створена мапа випадків захворювань.
Мобільний застосунок показує присутність можливого носія інфекції
поблизу власника мобільного телефону з цим додатком.
Програма відстежує геолокацію телефону
та інформує про наближення до потенційно небезпечного місця, не чекаючи запиту.
Використовується супутникова система навігації.
Додаток зберігає інформацію про переміщення людини.
Міністерство цифрової трансформації України створило додаток "Дій Вдома"
для контролю обов'язкової самоізоляції.
Застосунок має контролювати тих, хто вже є носієм вірусу,
або може потенційно ним стати.
Перелік таких громадян визначають епідеміологи МОЗ.
Ці громадяни надають письмову згоду на встановлення застосунку та обробку своїх даних.
Застосунок упродовж двох тижнів надсилає користувачам до 10 push-повідомлень на день.
У відповідь на повідомлення впродовж 15 хвилин треба зробити селфі.
Під час фотографування зчитується геолокація.
Якщо впродовж 15 хвилин користувач нічого не надсилає - йде сповіщення до поліції.
Правоохоронці можуть зателефонувати або приїхати до людини на самоізоляції
за адресою, яку та добровільно дала напередодні.